a mini cowboy Curtis turbine hall Dyson
/ says the MINI Convertible lets in lots
of light and air but he feels an
open-top car should be practical and
fuel-efficient two minis are mainly
lifestyle vehicles geared towards
driving pleasure the cars incredibly
responsive handling is evident right
from the start the shifting is crisp
steering direct the many spoils drivers
with its sporty performance our Cooper
convertibles fuel mileage is acceptable
though that's all it needs 5.7 liters of
fuel to cover 100 kilometers and the car
takes nine point eight seconds to
accelerate from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour so it's snapped for speed demons
however the mini soft top is clever and
practical to demonstrate that we close
it in spite of the beautiful weather
doesn't mean vinyl says this isn't a car
for folks who don't want their hair
mussed up as it can get pretty drafty
with the top down however the mini is
one of the few cars to have a soft top
with a sunroof so you can enjoy the
great outdoors without messing up your
hair the opening is also great because
you can use it to wave at other mini
drivers and you can put the roof up and
down while driving at speeds of up to 30
kilometers an hour it opens within 15
seconds
on the outside the mini is all retro
styling with curves and chrome
everywhere you look
the roof takes up most of the trunk
space leaving about 170 litres of space
for other things the curves and chrome
continue inside the many a large
speedometer surrounds the satellite
navigation system on the dashboard the
always open timer precisely measures the
time spent driving with the top down
many convertible drivers like to boast
on forums about how much time they've
had with the top open the top should be
up when parking the convertible but that
can be problematic doesn't any copy our
car tester finds the mini convertible
great fun to drive and really likes the
sunroof but he thinks the blind spot is
very noticeable whether the roofs up or
down he encourages you to add the
parking assistance system from the
customization options it's difficult to
park or maneuver without it especially
if you don't have someone along to jump
out and guide you and that would look
too cool anyway Lincoln cause of them
set us up garnish cool house
and the mini cooper convertible is
designed to be cool unfortunately it
scores no points for storage space or
low fuel consumption but it's a really
fun car whether you've got somewhere to
go or you're just out for a spin it's
lifestyle on wheels the Cooper model
will set you back just under twenty four
thousand euros in Germany if you're
looking to save on fuel a good option
would be the diesel model for twenty
five thousand euros which takes just
four litres per 100 kilometers